good day everyone and welcome i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
and i'm proud to welcome you to this
edition of our
2021-2022 foundations of biomedical data
science seminar series this lecture
series is supported by uva's integrated
translational health institute of
virginia the uva brain institute the
college of arts and sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from
the national institutes of general
medical sciences this year's theme is
ethical challenges of artificial
intelligence and biomedicine where we
enjoy presentations on friday afternoons
from leading thinkers about the promise
opportunities and hurdles associated
with ai applications in the biomedical
sciences
selected participants in our biomedical
data science innovation lab program will
leverage these presentations as vital
material for our culminating in-person
grant project development workshop to be
held here in historic charlottesville
virginia in june
today i am delighted to welcome our
speaker dr jan jolie from the mcgill
university in montreal canada he is a
full professor in the faculty of medical
sorry medicine department of human
genetics and cross-appointed the
bioethics unit and mcgill university
where he is research director of the
center for genomics and policy he has
been at mcgills i just learned since
2009 and he serves as the current chair
of the bioethics work group of the
international human epigenome consortium
and the co-lead of the regulatory and
ethics work stream of the global
alliance for genomics and health
professor jelly's research interests lie
at the interface of the fields of
scientific knowledge health law
and bioethics in continuing with our
theme for this year in terms of our
seminar series dr uh joey's lecture will
be entitled addressing key challenges in
genomic health and data sharing the
importance of studying large and diverse
biomedical data sets is a major advance
is now widely recognized and big data is
central to the concept of learning
health care systems and applying them to
ai in the health field and following on
this governments publishers and other
stakeholders are actively encouraging
the sharing of data as we will learn
professors jolie's presentation today
will discuss some of the key challenges
to sharing data and highlight recent
strategies and tools developed by the
international community to address them
as always we are streaming this lecture
live and for recording via youtube and
if you are watching by youtube thank you
for joining us also our specially
selected 2021 2022 biomedical data
science innovation lab participants are
encouraged to submit any questions they
have by the chat feature in their zoom
sessions i'll synthesize these questions
and i will ask them on your behalf
during the last 10 minutes or so in the
lecture and with that yan thank you so
much we are super excited to hear from
you today
thank you for the kind introduction
professor van horn and thank you for the
foundation of biomedical data sciences
and for and the university of virginia
for the kind invitation to present here
today
so i will start with the official
disclosure
as
was mentioned in the introduction i am
currently the co-lead of the global
alliance for genomic and health uh
regulatory and ethics work stream
and i am the scientific director and ceo
of an organization called the genetic
discrimination observatory and uh both
of these organizations will be discussed
in the presentation and some of the
tools
from these organizations will also be uh
presented
so i think that uh it's safe to say that
our topic for today
uh genomics and health data sharing
is is something that's extremely timely
uh that is uh in full spotlight uh for
everybody
that is uh working in genomic research
and in other ohmic sciences
uh you've all heard about
the new upcoming uh data sharing policy
from the nih uh they already of course
added data sharing uh policy but this is
basically reinforcing this policy
expanding it and modernizing it and it's
going to impact
everyone involved in in biomedical
research and beyond so i think it's very
important
to discuss some of the
implications that that this policy and
and other similar policy will have for
researchers
uh and i'm gonna take uh an
international perspective to this
discussion uh but at the same time
the challenges are very similar all over
the world
in terms of what
this can
how this will impact researchers uh so
with that being said let me just change
to my next slide i'm struggling a bit
with uh the slight change but that's it
fixed okay so this is the outline for
the talk today uh so we'll start by
discussing how did we get there uh how
did we get to this broad data sharing
uh movement in in scientific research
and in genetics more specifically
then we'll be discussing about you know
what is what is different if anything
about uh genetic data that that warrants
us to to discuss it in the specific
context and how can we account for that
as we're going to be
sharing our data
then we will really start uh with the
going into the arc of our topic and
we'll really discuss
uh four uh different domains
uh that have been specifically uh that
have caused specific challenges to data
sharing and and will also uh
briefly look at what could be some
opportunities and solutions to address
the challenges uh raised by these
different dome
domains and and i hope after the talk we
can have a fruitful conversation and
really the objective is to be
has sort of helpful and accessible in
the information i'll be conveying
we can get to very granular level in the
questions but i'll be staying at the
mostly general level for the
presentation to cover the large
scope
that i am trying to cover
so how did we get there uh well it's
it's been a long uh trip uh it started
really this discussion about open data
sharing uh started with
the human genome project where really we
tried we there was this competition to
get the full sequence of the human
genome
as quickly as possible uh between the
public and private uh basically uh team
uh of researchers in the states and and
really uh it was
in in the process of doing this uh human
genome project that we found out
important collaboration
and data sharing was and that's the
first time
some of the key principles on uh we
should share data what kind of data
should be shared
and and key consideration
on how to share it
uh so
this was in 1996
uh soon again it was felt that this is
working well this data sharing uh we
need to expand it
uh and and that's where we started
thinking about it's expanding it to
different data set also thinking about
uh different stakeholders in data
sharing because one of the you know
issues if you want researchers to share
their data is
they're not going to do it by themselves
they need help it's a complicated
process to change to share your data it
can be cumbersome so it's an ecosystem
project really data sharing
and other stakeholders such as
research funders such as publishers
institutions
may have a responsibility
in making this data sharing possible and
in ensuring this data sharing so that
was uh sort of what the fort lauderdale
was pushing towards
uh and and also
we have to think
uh beyond just human genetics when we
talk think about data sharing and and
that's been a bit of a challenge because
very soon in the process
a different regime was established for
non-human genetic material
by an international convention
on biodiversity which which
interestingly enough the us is is one of
the country that is not part of this
convention but a large number of other
countries are so when we talk about
international data sharing that
convention is very relevant and that
convention was reinforced
by the nagoya protocol in 2010 on access
and benefit sharing
and really the impact of that protocol
has been that it really limited data
sharing in wanting to protect
uh the
the non-human genetic data of developing
country which is of course a great idea
the problem is it has really uh
complexified the way that non-human
genetic data could be shared
and for that reason and after
a few pandemics warning in in 2011 who
adopted
pandemic influenza preparedness
framework
to allow and facilitate
genetic data while the sharing of
biomedical data including genetic data
in the context of pandemic and to sort
of facilitate it uh
as i mentioned it had became quite
challenging with nagoya so it was really
sort of coming back and saying well in
case of pandemic here's what needs to
take precedence uh so all of these
documents by the way that i am
mentioning right now are all available
and i i do recommend that people that
are interested in data sharing consult
them they're all quite helpful uh so uh
next in 2013
uh an an alliance uh basically a
consortium
of over 500 public and private partners
organ institutional partners called the
global alliance for genomics and health
was created really to promote
data sharing to develop the kind of
tools
that were essential
to promote data sharing
and
basically they developed both
bioinformatics tools
and
also ethical tools to make this
large-scale data sharing possible
uh and and they work across several work
streams that focus on different
specificity of data sharing
uh
so that uh that alliance was created in
2013
uh in
2016 the fair uh guiding principle uh
for scientific data management and
stewardship uh were uh agreed upon and
released in a publication and these
principles are very important because
they basically set forward how you
should be preparing your data uh so that
it is accessible uh and and usable by
researchers again across different
domains
uh
in order to verify your methodology
uh and to build upon
uh your innovations
uh then uh in uh more recently in 2019
so you see again that that
interestingly enough
uh this uh the non-human genetic data uh
sector is a little bit trailing behind
uh the human genetic data and i i see
it's interesting because
personally as an ethicist i could tell
you there's less ethical challenge
probably in sharing non-human genetic
data than in sharing human genetic data
nevertheless uh it's only in 2019
that the public health alliance for
genomic epidemiology was uh set forward
uh and uh it's basically an
international alliance that does similar
work to what the global alliance does uh
but in the non-human uh genetic sector
uh and and finally of course uh i can't
not mention uh kobit 19 which has been a
game changer uh in the field of data
sharing so uh of uh in january 2020 uh
coven 19 uh was declared by who to be a
public health emergency of international
concern
and and as most of you know uh there's
been uh
first of all genetics has really come to
the spotlight uh with uh
coven 19 because we've been extremely
interested and had to study the variance
uh of kovid their different effect uh
and and how they emerge and follow their
outbreak their development and evolution
etc which was all done through genetics
and does the importance again of not
just collecting that information but
sharing it uh across region countries
and and making it available for the
community of researcher around the world
so now let's think a little bit about
genetic data and and think about what
what is so special about genetic data
that we should really uh have special
procedure or be careful when when
sharing this data
uh again from an ethical
legal social perspective
so first thing that we can say about uh
genetic information is that it is
uniquely identifying
uh it can be used because it's uniquely
identifying
we can use that information also to
discriminate between individual and we
can use it for profiling purpose
uh how can we use it to discriminate
between individual
well genetic information of course uh
can be predictive of not only
uh current health we have diagno genetic
diagnostic tests that exist
uh so so genes can be indicative
of a disease but most of the time they
can also be predictive of future health
of course most disease a genetic
component as we all know
so
that information is of course of
interest to other parties than just
medical researchers
uh
patient
it's also of interest to people like
insurers
employers
uh
military uh organization etc
uh because of its predictive nature and
and of course uh this is an information
genetic information
that we share with not just you know
it's not just uh unique to us but we
share it with both our close and distant
relatives so sometime with whole
population group and and of course all
of humanity shares together in a
substantial proportion of the human
genome
so because of these characteristics
of
genetic information
what was proposed quite early on
there was this spirit of thought that is
called genetic exceptionalism
and and what was really behind this
current of thought was really uh saying
because genetic information has these
unique characteristics it's very
sensitive
and it should be protected by law
at a higher level we should have more
stringent protection over this type of
information than over other types of
medical information or personal
uh data
and and
genetic exceptionalism we might not hear
the word as often today but it is still
quite relevant and and a lot of people
have this in mind when they talk about
protecting genetic information about
genetic privacy etc so it's still very
influential
but there are strong arguments however
that have emerged against genetic
exceptionalism
so for one thing uh it's been shown that
you know it was not just genetic
biomarkers that could be predictive
of future health a lot of non-genetic
biomarkers can also predict future
health so for example we can talk about
cholesterol level
uh we can talk
about blood pressure
we can talk about a lot of other types
of biomarkers that are also predictive
of future health
in fact i remember a year and a half ago
there was this famous article which
presented 14
non-genetic biomarker they were mostly
chemical biomarkers that were predictive
uh of debt uh in in the fairly near
future i think it was over 10 and 20
years
so not something unique to genetic
information
uh and also we've seen the emergence of
a lot of new uh disciplines linked with
genetics such as epigenetic
pharmacogenetic
microbiomics and all those data share a
lot of characteristics with genetic
information they're predictive they can
be unique identifier of an individual
and by unique identifier i mean really
that it takes a little bit of that type
of information
to really uh
identify an individual
uniquely as in this is you know the code
that that belongs to this particular
individual
of course it's not the same thing as
having the full identifying information
on that person but nevertheless it's
going to be very helpful to re-identify
to find out the identity of a person if
you have another database
of course there's other types of data
even that share characteristics
with genetic information i've given a
few examples on the slide lifestyle
environment demographic data etc so
for all of these reasons uh it makes one
wonder should we really have a specific
focus on genetic and and give it that
extra amount of protection is it really
warranted and and furthermore it's been
put forward as well that we should be
careful because the more uh true or laws
to our media
we make genetic information as being the
sort of
pandora's box uh of of information that
raise a high level of risk and that's
very stigmatizing well we're creating
this this sort of negative
image of what genetic information is and
we're participating in stigmatizing it
more than than we should really be
so we have to be careful that in over
protecting it we might actually make it
more vulnerable so these were sort of
the arguments that have been put forward
against genetic exceptionalism and and
still today this sort of debate of
should genetic information uh be
protected more than other health data or
or not
it's still ongoing
to this day and it has a big impact on
public policy
so let's check our first sort of area
that we will be discussing
so it's the area of data privacy so of
course the first hurdle that you will
often hear when it comes to time to
share data is that well there are legal
and ethical requirements uh you know and
and institutional administrative
requirements that basically makes it
very complicated or prevent me as a
researcher to share the data so the
first level
privacy is the first level in a way of
hurdle that is often
raised against data sharing and of
course privacy is important because
privacy is requisite of trust
if you cannot
trust the system as a patient or as a
research participant you're not going to
provide your information so it does make
sense to guarantee to people that will
be able to reasonably protect their
information and that's what privacy is
all about
uh privacy of course applies to personal
data which means that it needs to belong
to a person
if i find um
a blog spot on the street
it's not personal data because what it
is is biological information but i can't
associate it uh to a person's identity
without going through an unreasonable
amount of
uh
challenge both from a technical level
legal level etc so because this blood
spot uh is sufficiently de-identified
it's not associated uh with a specific
individual uh it's not personal data
according to and and then it's not
protected by privacy law uh similarly
uh properly de-oced and that's very
important and was very important
in the context of uh kovid a properly
de-hosted virus genome sequence does not
constitute personal
data what do i mean thereby properly
deocent
well sometimes when you sequence
the covalent virus that you've collected
from a human patient
uh there is a bit of human genetic data
left mixed tangled with the viral genome
sequence so you have to de-host it but
once that is done uh you're talking
about the viral sequence you're talking
about the genome sequence of a virus so
it's not human data it's not personal
data it's not identifying therefore it
can be shared quite easily because it
doesn't fall under the scope of privacy
law last point i want to make about
privacy
most of the researchers that work
internationally are aware of the general
data protection regulation i have a
feeling you'll probably hear more about
it
in the context of other seminars of this
series uh it's just uh inconcernable you
cannot go around the general data
protection regulation it's a european
regulation uh that carries extra
territorial weight and that it applies
beyond the european border and it's made
to protect uh the data privacy uh it's
however uh a very contemporary approach
at protecting uh information it imposes
a lot of new responsibility over
researchers
and so if you're going to be sharing
your data internationally
especially if you're going to be taking
in european data you absolutely must
know about the requirement of gender of
the the gdpr and be able to meet those
requirements otherwise you will not be
able to share data with european
colleagues
uh how do we protect privacy very
quickly there are several ways
so again it's not something that is
unfeasible
there are several approach to protecting
your data
these are just a few key approaches to
do that you can de-identify your data so
basically you remove some of the
metadata that is associated with your
genomic data uh and up to a point where
it's
extreme becomes extremely complicated to
re-identify it basically you have this
genetic sequence but uh you cannot
uh link that genetic sequence with an
individual's identity
the identity of a specific
individual without unreasonable effort
so you de-identify your genetic material
by removing for example the name of the
person it belongs to
where they live their social insurance
number etc uh of course uh there are
laws in the u.s like ipa i know as some
specific requirement for the
identification i'm not gonna go there
today uh but they are a good starting
place to
see what's needed to de-identify
information
i.t security tools are all the
information technology
programs
software tools that you can use to
protect your data they go from very
simple things but that you know
everybody sort of know are needed such
as firewall all your normally all good
university at firewalls to protect the
data of the university uh coding
encryption which has become increasingly
sophisticated password access etc
beyond that there are administrative
measures you can take and and are taken
to protect data when you're dealing with
sensitive data you use a tiered access
system where basically people have to
agree to some specific contractual terms
if they want to see your data
so that's what we call the tiered access
system that's where you have those
repository like dbgap that have access
committee
that have specific requirement to give
you access to the data
nowadays also uh we hear a lot about
data federation what's data federation
uh sometimes specific database are not
willing to share the data
they want to keep the data in the
database
and then what you can do is sometime
have a specific
link between different
database and you can ask your query
through a single portal and obtain the
information
from that access portal without viewing
what's in the database you only view the
answer to your question in a
non-identifiable
format so you basically protecting each
local database but
making it possible to query them and to
obtain a single answer
from these various databases
of course
uh we're at the day and age where
everybody should know that you can't
protect
privacy
uh completely you can only do your best
you can only do a reasonable effort and
that must be made clear to patient
research participant etc uh what
basically you want to do is be
transparent and say here's what i can do
and here's what i'm doing to protect
your data of course explain it in in
terms that the late public can
understand and also it's nowadays uh one
concept that has become extremely
important is that of imputability
somebody has to take responsibility
for protecting the information we need
to know who these people are
very often now
you are required as an institution for
example
if you're going to share data according
to the gdpr that i mentioned you need to
have a data
privacy officer a person that's
responsible
for privacy at your institution
and that's part of this idea of
imputability
now why is it
important to protect
uh genetic information
well for for many reason i mean it is
personal information of course and and
everybody know what what privacy breach
can be conducive to but the problem
that's been particular to genetic and
that has been discussed a lot in the
media especially in the united states is
the issue of genetic discrimination it's
a question i've studied for many years
uh and and one thing that's interesting
about genetic discrimination is that the
actual incidence of genetic
discrimination uh is is fairly
uh a limited in terms of uh i mean
what we can do with genetic information
right now especially uh looking at the
predictivity of genetic information is
limited uh to a lot of monogenic highly
penetrant disorder
of course we're now starting to move
beyond that
we have we're even talking about
polygenic risk or but if you want to be
able
to uh predict what's almost certainty uh
the development of a disease in a way
that this information could be available
and could be of interest to insurers
employer etc
you're limited in the number of disease
etc that's why the incidence of genetic
discrimination
has not been uh extremely widespread
it's not been seen all over uh the
different use of genetic that we make in
the research and medical cons context
but nevertheless especially in the us
it's been a problem and and people are
quite concerned about genetic
discrimination they need to be reassured
they need to know that their genetic
information
uh is protected
and and uh
one word maybe about the math that you
can see on this slide is just to give
you a sense of uh the studies that have
been done on genetic discrimination on
the topic of life insurance and what it
shows you is that we know very little
still about the phenomenon of genetic
discrimination and in order to address
it uh and to develop laws uh that will
be efficient against genetic
discrimination there's a need to study
it uh in much more details because our
laws are not that effective yet at
countering these problems
uh and and we're also we also have to
think nowadays about uh stigmatization
and discrimination at the level of
population this is going to become one
key issue in genetic because we want to
have a data set that are more diverse we
want to represent minority group of the
population in our studies so that they
can benefit from research but in doing
that
this
the effect is that there might be some
use of this information to stigmatize or
discriminate these populations so we
have to be very careful as we're
proceeding in this uh good direction of
including more minority group in the
research
and for those interested in this
please contact me at the genetic
discrimination observatory what we do is
really attempt to tackle this genetic
discrimination issue the way that i
believe it should be done which is at
the international level
because genetic information is now
shared across national border we cannot
have this
local view of genetic discrimination
mind you it's important to be active at
the local and national level but we also
need to add this larger uh perspective
on it of how can we adopt again rules
that are coherent at the international
level to prevent genetic discrimination
uh i spoke about the importance of
diversity
uh
it's it's another of these big questions
now uh in in data sharing so how can we
make sure that we're not sharing only
data on white people of european
ancestry how can we be more inclusive in
the data types that we take on uh
and and use so we first of all have to
understand why some of these
minority groups are reluctant to
participate and one of the first reason
is what we call intersectionality which
is very often uh it's the same group
that are already victimized
based on racial discrimination based on
poverty
on access to health care etc that are
the most at risk of again being
victimized by let's say genetic
discrimination it always fall on the
same group which is why you're sort of
reluctant when you talk to them about
participating in genetic research so one
of the first
thing that should be realized is this
this problem of intersectionality and
how can we address it uh to make uh
these population uh that have been uh
victimized and more marginalized by
society how can we make them confident
that that with genetic research this is
going to be different and need to
benefit for them
uh
considering them and including them in
our data as i said it's an ethical and
medical imperative any scientist will
tell you in genetics that if you only
use data from a white european
population
well you're only going to get robust
genetic result for those population and
so your result will only have limited
application and will not benefit a lot
large population group within even a
single country
uh so how do you do this how can you
make sure you have these groups you have
to start early if you want to include uh
these minority population group you have
to engage them early to know what their
expectations are are there specific
terms of engagement for them to
participate
that are important for them you need to
build the trust that has been eroded
over the years of abuse
so the earlier you can start engaging
them in the process the better it is and
collecting data is not sufficient uh we
have some type database that actually
took it upon themselves to collect this
data but because the data is still in
smaller quantity then uh the data of
european population the data basically
lay dormant and database and is not used
by researchers uh
there's a duty for scientific researcher
to use this data it's really important
uh and so they should almost justify not
using it if they're not going to use all
the data from the different population
data
that are in a database
so again some tips to to
increase the participation of minority
population think about whether specific
uh consent modalities uh would be useful
think about maybe how to address the
concern that there might be data misuse
or genetic discrimination uh is is a law
needed or some sort of regulation to
give them more protection etc uh
also self-governance is becoming
extremely important for those community
so they want to have some seen what is
done in the data they want to be
involved
uh they want to benefit from the
research capacity building is important
equitable access to drugs that may be
developed from the research might be a
consideration and and finally uh it's
it's it's you need to
from the get-go uh build this
relationship and start this engagement
but also as regulator i think it's
critically important that strong metrics
are developed to then be able to assess
uh how researchers have performed on on
this particular task of including more
diverse uh population uh in in their
data set and and use this data in their
research so metrics are key uh i've put
one article that's proposing interesting
metrics and interesting metrics approach
in the context of coven 19 so you may
want to have a look
at that particular article
another key area if you're thinking of
sharing data
is the area of attribution and reward
uh it's often sometimes we don't think
about it we sort of assume that the
people who produce the data
that create the database uh that they
will share their data uh they will not
automatically share their data i used to
have
uh a slide uh those of you that are
familiar with the lord of the ring uh
know the creature golom and i i often
would compare a researcher's
relationship to their data with that of
golem in the ring in that it is
it is their treasure the data is the
treasure of the researcher so how do you
get them to share this treasure well you
get you get them to do that by giving
them something that they would like to
have
and and these are some suggestions of
what should be given to researcher
of course co-authorship might be
warranted in some cases sometimes it
might just be more of an acknowledgement
there might be collaboration
requirements uh the problem right now
with that is that those rules
vary by discipline
by country
they're not as
well aligned at the international level
and for example between the human
genetics and the public health genetics
branch uh they're very different and so
when you want these branches to
collaborate it's going to make things
more complicated because they're going
to have different expectations
uh additional funding of course funders
need to contribute to data sharing it's
not going to happen without a cost and
so somebody asked your help researchers
with the cost of data sharing uh
there's been other mechanisms sometimes
to anchorage researcher that i like a
bit less
embargo is an example where basically
we're going to say to a researcher
it's it's almost like a patent where you
say to a researcher well you can share
your data
and uh will will embargo it meaning
nobody's going to use it people are
going to be able to view it but it's
going to take a couple of years before
they can actually
do something with it so that you have a
head start
it becomes problematic especially if the
embargo is for a substantially long
period of time
another one that i'm not a fan on is is
intellectual property right uh i think
they need especially if you're upstream
in the research process and genetic uh i
would not recommend the use of ip right
i think that you know you want to make
it clear actually that uh you shouldn't
be patenting anything like raw genomic
data first of all in most patent system
across the world uh patenting raw
genomic data is is not
something that's possible but it's also
really not conducive
to good collaborative uh science
so beyond all of these elements that
i've just mentioned now
uh there are a lot of administrative
burden that make data sharing
complicated
and so
this is for example you know it's almost
like a checklist if a researcher's car
because very often i have colleagues at
the university that are starting and
it's sort of the first time that they
are into a big uh genetic project and
they come to me and they say well what
do i need to do to share my data what do
i need to think of so these are all the
administrative steps that will likely
have to happen for you uh to be able to
share your data uh you're gonna have to
have a consent
form where you're gonna recruit research
participant
that's gonna be fairly broad meaning
that it's gonna allow you to do
many things with the data uh it's not
gonna be uh permitting research on a
really specific disease no it's going to
be i want to use my the data i'm
collecting from you
in all kinds of medical research it's
going to permit to you to share your
data internationally all these things
have to be included in the in the
consent so you need to really tailor
your informed consent very carefully uh
as you start recruiting participant then
also before you get started you're going
to need a governance
model a governance framework for your
database and a data access model as in
what are the requirements that people
are going to have to meet
in order to access my data
finally
well you're gonna also have to think
about what are the specific privacy uh
requirement and setting that my database
will have so uh is the data that is
going to be stored in my database is it
going to be coded genetic data so
basically i don't have any direct
identifiers such as a name
uh
or a social insurance number but i may
have indirect identifier and there is a
code that links
uh my genetic information uh with the
name and somebody is able to let's say
uh
link the genetic information with the
medical file of the participant so we're
talking coded data here that can be how
you're gonna work in your database or it
could be anonymized data where you
decide that you're not gonna
no longer need the personal information
and so you strip it permanently you're
talking more about anonymized data and
about de-identified data set if you do
that so these are some of the privacy
setting and all of the other things that
we talked about uh when we covered the
question
of uh privacy
then we're gonna have to think about
ethics approval
uh or is the data
that's in my database first of all am i
needing a net ex approval to collect it
uh from participant do i need to have
their consent as we've mentioned uh do i
need a text approval but also
furthermore will researchers that want
to have access to my database need to
have a netix approval in order to access
my data so you have to think about this
in both direction if you're providing
data access
you also have to set up your data access
comedy
if you're going to be giving access to
sensitive data and prepare data access
agreement of course
there's way to circumvent some of these
burden so you may want to use dbgap as a
repository for your data in that case uh
they have their own data access
committee uh of course you will still
stipulate the access conditions or
what's in the access agreement to some
extent
but they will provide the infrastructure
the committee etc so some of these steps
can be circumvented
and finally of course there's a whole
technical steps
that
is required to prepare
the data uh
for the user and and the download time
so all of these things that also
uh need to be considered
so in concluding my presentation before
we open it to question uh i would say
that that these are some
uh these are some steps that i would say
are part of a path forward that will
make life easier for people that want to
share data so
early preparedness is key uh nowadays if
you're going to do large-scale genetic
research don't think you're going to do
much in the first years because you're
not anybody that's been in the business
will tell you
you're going to take about a year or
more two years some time to just engage
the population group that you want to
recruit and to develop uh your your
governance framework for your data
so this is part of the cost of you know
sharing data that you have to keep in
mind early engagement with vulnerable
population
uh and and also
you need to really uh think uh again
from a really perspective
uh way of okay
what are the risks that uh my data incur
from the start
what's the risk what could be some of
the possible worst event
uh how can i prevent them and how can i
convey to my participant the level of
privacy that i'll be able to provide to
the data
uh damn i think that a really important
step and and as for the entire research
community
uh is to limit the number of data
repository uh you know there there is uh
some time uh you know this this feeling
of again it's my data therefore you know
i want my own representatory because i
want to be in control
uh there's there's that desire to even
though you know and you have no choice
but to share your data to want to retain
control of the data and therefore to
think well i'll have my own repository
this way i can really control things
uh it's it's it's really not a good idea
unless you have a strong reason to do
that other than just controlling the
data otherwise i would say simply use
you know a larger repository make sure
that the condition that that of access
respond to your particular need
but but please don't multiply repository
it just makes data access more
complicated and more procedural across
the board for everybody
and try to keep the administrative step
to access data to district minimum
you don't always need a complex data
access agreement followed by a material
transfer agreement followed by piecemeal
negotiation process you can very often
you know have this done in a very
limited amount of step via a very
simple agreement and this is what people
should strive to do
and and finally as i said this is an
ecosystem we're not just a researcher of
responsibilities
but all the different parts of the
ecosystem need to be involved and
funding
agency especially need to provide
the financial cost that is required to
share data
for researchers
and i i want to also and i think this is
going to be really important for
researchers working in this field these
are some of the key
uh good practices
that i would really direct you to uh
that could be extremely useful if you
want to develop
a repository and and have a governance
framework that's going to be uh strong
from a fair data access and
international data access perspective
here are some of the key
uh documents and guidelines that really
you would need to follow and to take
into account and i'll be happy to speak
more specifically some of these if there
are questions
uh and i want to thank you uh very much
for listening be happy to answer a
question
as you can see that my dogs and cats
were there uh doing the oversight uh
while i was present preparing my
presentation so i i want to acknowledge
their help as well and and of course all
the funders uh thank you very much and
and we can open it to questions thank
you so much john i really appreciate
your comments uh my first question is do
you have to offer your dogs and your
cats co-authorships on anything that uh
you produce
i i i think that again you know you you
need to think about enticement and now i
can get them to cooperate and i think
food's more appropriate for tonight
very food motivated you know you brought
up in all seriousness you got several
different elements and i i liked how you
really kind of uh touched on the tension
that exists between openness of data and
security
and the research potential that that
data has that kind of that that triad of
push-pull relationships with exit that
exists on that
i i'm very curious to to get your sense
of like
what is it that keeps people from really
wanting to share their data sometimes
people hide behind security and say oh i
couldn't do it and my irb will never let
me do it but on the other hand that sort
of can be kind of perceived sometimes as
a cop-out are there other reasons why
people might not want to share their
data or hide behind you know sort of
i don't know not necessarily the the
best reasons to to share their data
right so today we we've addressed the
real hurdles of course
uh there are very often other reason and
and and with kovitz some of these
reasons have become quite apparent
so i would i will only name two for
example uh i think a lot of time when
when you talk
about data sharing with a commercial
enterprise with pharmaceutical company
or biotech small biotech startup
uh well
they're worried about sharing their data
because for them it's it's an asset and
and uh you know they have to make a
profit it's not like a publicly funded
researcher right where you can have the
argument of well you're funded by the
public and your research should directly
benefit the public so in those cases uh
very often but but to be fair even some
publicly funded researchers will want to
keep their data secret uh to to have a
commercial advantage
or what they perceive to be a commercial
advantage because they're afraid that if
they don't share uh they'll be scooped
uh another interesting phenomenon that
we've seen during covet is uh really
public health uh sometime being public
health agencies uh not always being
willing to share their data with the
research community and interestingly one
of the key reason why they don't like to
do that
was a fear that their data was going to
be misrepresented by researcher
that
you know it could be used to show that
they had done mistake in their own work
or
uh to give an image that would be for
example more alarmist
uh
than than than what the situation was
really in a given state or province
and so they they sort of felt that it
was sort of written demanded some time
to prevent that sharing in order to to
protect these i would say personal
interest and and when i say that i'm
mostly building from my experience in
canada where i was quite involved in
data sharing for research uh but i i
don't know you can you can tell me if
that also resonates within what with
what happened in the us
oh yeah absolutely lots of people have
um
a lot of reasons they'll say well i
don't have the staff to do that i don't
have the funds to support it um
but even
just in my own experience i've
experienced where people will say well
my experiment is too complicated for me
to explain it to you so i'm not going to
share my data and if you point out to
people that perhaps that doesn't meet
the definition of science
then
they they don't tend to like that so
much
but on the other hand there are these
sort of enticements as you referred to
earlier things like co-authorships or
certainly acknowledgements or
collaborations on grants or or you know
some some uh you know funding related
activities you know at what point do
some of these relationships become
sort of a quid pro quo kind of you know
cost of doing business i want to use
this data and now i have to give these
people an acknowledgement or a
co-authorship which i hadn't intended to
do but now i have to do it it some
people see that as a negative and so it
actually means that they don't use
certain repositories that they might
otherwise want to take advantage of do
you find that as well
uh yes i mean i i i it happens
i think the key here is is as you say
it's a key proco so you really need to
uh both parties need to find an
advantage there and and so
one of the problem right now as i
mentioned is those rules are not
harmonized
and in some field those rules are
extremely restrictive such as you cannot
use
my data
if you don't you know if if i don't
agree with what you're proposing to do
i want to see a plan i want you to then
share your result with me so that i can
use your result myself
uh i so so plenty of conditions that
that can make it quite complicated
you're not gonna patent uh your result
ever uh things like that
so i think that that the key here
is really working hard on this
harmonization
of uh acknowledgement and and
attribution rules and and first of all
start within broad sectors
uh and then really even across sectors
because i would say that that very often
uh there's no real strong justification
why would for example
in in in one sector
somebody that produces data
would need to be a co-author on a
publication in order to share his or her
data while in another sector uh simply
give them a thank you or acknowledging
the repository uh through a citation
uh format is is sufficient uh you know
it's
we we we should be agreeing on whether
we're we're okay with citation and and
acknowledgement which i think is is
enough in most cases or whether
sometimes co-authorship is is really
warranted and i would say that only
where there's a real collaboration and
and the substantial role of the data
producer in the final paper uh would
would this uh co-authorship really be
warranted
so with regard to collaboration
what can early career researchers do to
get involved with efforts like your own
to help improve the data sharing
policy and practice
well i think i think for
for the next few years uh just
documenting the experience of those
early researchers is gonna be key
because uh one of the strongest argument
against data sharing is that
it has a really
important adverse impact
on
early career researchers and on people
who have smaller genetic project because
mainly they risk being scooped and and
also uh the cost is just too heavy for
them to bear so i think it's really
important for them to speak out
make sure that the challenges the
immediate data sharing uh is is is well
reflected and is heard by sp by research
funders so that we can adopt you know we
can adapt the rules of data sharing uh
for them uh to be fair to to those new
players and those important players if
we wanted to happen across the board we
really have to have a system that's
going to have that built-in flexibility
where again data sharing is going to be
attractive by everyone for everyone in
the ecosystem and right now i don't
think it is as attractive as it should
be uh for for newer researchers and and
small scale researcher who have to learn
all those rules and think about all
those processes that they need to do if
they ever want to get into big data and
ai
john thank you so much for sharing your
your your thoughts with us and very
thought-provoking about how we can
improve upon data sharing how we can do
just better what that means for our
science uh respectively and what it
means internationally that this is so
absolutely vital i was really
felt that that was a really strong
statement we have to do this
internationally because different
countries have different rules we need
to communicate with each other science
knows doesn't know
you know political boundaries or
geographic boundaries we we really need
to improve things across the the planet
if we're going to uh be successful
scientifically moving into the deeper
into the 21st century and beyond so
thank you so much for sharing your
thoughts with us uh this has been really
helpful and uh i want to thank you again
thanks everybody who joined us and
everyone have a